some people love getting noticed claire
crawley's bachelorette journey
isn't over just yet for me i'm like
not only is the hair stylist still on
set but it appears she's still
filming i don't want to give up earlier
this month claire was replaced as the
show's lead by tasha adams
but new photos obtained by e.t taken on
sunday
show claire all dressed up in red
alongside host chris harrison
and long-time executive producer bennett
grabner
at the laquinta resort and club near
palm springs california
you know the same location where the
bachelorette has been filming
since last month i'm sorry say that
again
the sacramento native is all smiles in
the pics
sporting a chic one-shoulder number that
looks like the perfect dress for
possibly a fancy date or a rose ceremony
just saying full of shocking surprises
these pics come just days after claire
was photographed at the same resort
marking the first time she had been
spotted since sources confirmed to et
earlier this month
that she was being replaced on the hit
abc show this is insane
in one photo claire is seen with her dog
honey and
in another the reality star walks with a
man and a woman
and while we're not sure if they are
part of the show crew or if the man is a
contestant
we do know that the lead and the cast
are usually released from production
when their time on the series has come
to an
end so all this begs the question
is claire returning that's the question
a source told et earlier this month
that claire's time as the bachelorette
came to an end after she fell for one of
her men
but filming didn't stop new chapter new
page
yeah flip the script the source added
that producers are always embracing
twists
turns and new stories and that anything
can
happen
[Music]
meanwhile abc has been teasing claire's
season on social media
still showcasing her as the bachelorette
a source previously told et that claire
left
on good terms with producers and that
her journey to find love
will still very much be shown on tv so
fans are just gonna have to wait until
the new season of the bachelorette
premieres this fall
on abc i mean we shall see right